questions but no answers from the Labour
leader discrimination the subject under
discussion
in Spanish on the Corbin doorstep this
morning but not the discrimination that
schools of Labour MPs want the leader to
address a party confronted with the
testimony of eight former staff members
who insist allies of Jeremy Corbyn are
hampering the fight against
anti-semitism Sky News understands that
30 current and former Labour Party staff
members have come forward to help the
equality and human rights commission's
inquiry into anti-semitism in the party
two opposing views of who is to blame
practices and culture have been going
awry and it's been going awry since
Jeremy and I were elected leader and
deputy leader
I feel very responsible I think it's
important that we listen to what has
been said and look ourselves at what's
happening but as I say what we've got
now is two groups of staff challenging
each other about the accuracy of it so
we'll have to look at that but one
whistleblower told Sky News the buck
stops at the top and the issue won't go
away until Jeremy Corbyn leaves office
do you think that the eh RC could find
that labor is institutionally sent
anti-semitic but that the leader himself
isn't no I don't think so I think that
if you are to accept that the Labour
Party itself as a whole is auntie's and
is institutionally anti-semitic that
over the last four years it has gone
from being a proud anti-racist party to
something that has led to the resurgence
of racism and a really vile repugnant
form of racism I don't think that it's
possible for that to be the case and for
its leader not to be responsible for
what has happened there would anyone
around Jeremy Corbyn take a tougher line
do you see any difference between the
way that Jeremy Corbyn behaves and John
McDonnell yes I do I think that John
McDonnell understands that this issue is
political and electoral suicide for the
Labour Party I don't
necessarily think that that means that
he would go far enough or that it's
motivated by anything other than cynical
electoral reasons the equalities watch
Taku conclude as early as the new year
the problem with anti-semitism within
the labor party isn't going anywhere Sam
coats Sky News